look at us  two dope prom queens this is actually  making me sentimental  principal lamberg can suck it  oh my god you guys look amazing awkward  prom pic  [Laughter]  this was worth the wait thank you for  this punky  you have righted or wrong for two very  angsty teens it's a good day  hold up i am sensing a strange energy  with you  it's almost tranquil punky brewster have  you stopped waffling  i think maybe i closed the door too soon  and maybe the kiss wasn't a mistake  maybe i'm just caught up in all the  nostalgia of it but  after travis plays i'm gonna talk to him  omg prom drama do you guys think i'm  crazy am i crazy  no i'm yes but no what should i say  just open your heart and express  yourself  you're right i don't need to justify my  love  you know you two were speaking in  madonna's song titles right  yep i'm gonna sew madonna this thing  you